it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we bring you some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts so start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit
cbsdeals.com Candy Carter Chief content
officer for the e-commerce company
knocking is knocking at your door this
morning good morning let's get right to
it we have first of all we have so much
good stuff today go to cbsdeals.com
right now because everybody will be
shopping okay so a lot of people do yard
work in the summer when we got here
every single year I replace my water
hose my husband's like are you for real
buying another water hose and a lot of
people all the time we run over them
with the cars the tracks sell but these
are the Bernini water hoses so here's
the first one this is the fireman hose
it's literally the material that they
use for fire hoses look how light this
is super light you can bend it right in
the direction you can you can hold it oh
yeah you can do all kinds of stuff you
can get your gutters you can get your
car and it bends and stays and you can
even make it a sprinkler like oh so you
can like set it up yes have it on the
ground yeah sprinklers okay
stainless steel hose pick that up that
is lighter super light than a gallon of
milk that's a 75 foot water hose check
this out can your regular water hose do
this
no you can sneak it through your yard
all the water hose can't do that right
so it's super super light really durable
run over with the car hit it with an ax
nothing is cracking that water hose
what's the price on it they're amazing
so these are the deal price is 119.99 up
to 43 off oh these are game changers
this one will change everything oh well
change your life so cbsdeals.com get
these are going to sell out there that's
Tony asking the questions we need I know
I like that I I'm using these all summer
okay this is a rush charge UVC these
this is a universal charger so check out
this picture I'm at dinner the other
night nobody had a charger we're in the
middle of the room I took a picture
we're all charging our stuff look at
that then I'm on a flight with Mr
Connecticut hi he's watching he didn't
have a charger I didn't have a charger I
put that in the middle we were good
seven things can charge at once you can
even put your phone on top of it with
the cover on and it charges it but this
is why it's Universal my computer was
plugged in I needed to charge the
charger I just took my computer cord and
stuck it in there any input in here will
charge the charger and you can charge it
yes seven things at once you could
recharge a phone three times on this
battery so the retail price 199 and
119.99 44.99 63 off it's over 50 off 50
bucks okay deal yes okay thermal Comfort
super easy put this in the microwave for
two minutes it has a high neck right it
stays warm for 20 to 25 minutes it's got
a aroma therapy and a lot of women will
heat it up and put it on their stomach
for cramps you can also stick it in the
freezer for 30 minutes to an hour and it
stays cold for 30 minutes I use this the
other night 25 28 minutes I got out of
it and athletes can do a hot and cold
compress yeah 100 100 price on this oh
sorry
17.49. less than 20 you will spend more
for lunch today that was good too you
can use it every single day okay every
day these are a game changer okay I was
telling you I played golf I walked 18
holes this was like six or seven miles
came home took some Advil I'm old right
I go to bed and I have restless legs
like I couldn't sleep my legs were achy
and my muscles were twitching and I said
oh my gosh I have the legs I put them on
and laid in bed my husband's like look
at you I'm like this got me to sleep got
you to sleep
compression heat has four settings of
compression that's so good I only put it
on two professionals I just use this all
the time all day but here's the best
part they look huge they fold into this
little bag I keep it in my bathroom it's
great great this is the best money
you'll ever spend what's the price on it
137.99 it's normally 199. everybody was
asking me about them they're great yeah
they're like LeBron yes and my dad is
older and he uses them because you know
he's got circles I'm excited about these
all day long I'm wearing them okay last
time I was on two weeks ago I did these
socks look at this picture people have
been sending me pictures of them in
their socks candy I wore these all day
look at that no slip no slips with my
kids look at on the top no I've watched
these multiple times
I love these socks right here I told you
you know how many times I've bought a
type of soccer unbelievable and they
just slide under my foot I got the
sweaty heel all day okay here we go
11.99 to 59.95 the deal is 9.99 to 49.99
get the five pack it's perfect all right
Candy Carter we appreciate you of course
we partnered with all these companies to
get the deals to buy anything that you
saw today scan the QR code on your
screen right now or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping right now
we will be right back until me I'm
telling you you got to try these socks
all day